[Applause]
welcome back to las vegas now we are
prepping for back to school there's a
special partnership in town giving back
to elementary students in title one
schools with fitty foodie fit excuse me
at the helm so let's welcome foodie fits
jacob gallegos and alex lee to help us
help to tell us how we can
help you guys help everybody in the
community absolutely all right let's
first and foremost explain what foodie
fit does because you guys are a meal
prep service so you're really helping
the community all year round right
so our our concept was created six years
ago with myself and my two business
partners with the idea to
inspire and um
motivate our consumers to do what's
important to them for their time
absolutely so through that idea
foodie fit was born so with all the
delicious meals here but it's just
healthy meal prep
that's ready in about two minutes or
less
let me tell you from personal experience
i love foodie fit okay these meals are
so good and you feel good after you eat
them so let's just talk about some of
the options you have
absolutely
so the first item we have will go with
the breakfast it's our blueberry parfait
it's a non-fat greek yogurt
we actually mix with protein powder a
sugar-free blueberry compote and a
gluten-free oat crumble it's like the
best like power pack breakfast eyes
right ready quick on the go super light
and you would be hungry after but
you feel really good afterwards okay and
then of course you've got the big meals
yep um so something like a a good lunch
would be our
shrimp tacos
it's made the it's outside is wrapped
with a low-carb tortilla
cabbage
shrimp four ounces mango salsa and our
chipotle aioli and what's great about
the salsas too is that it's all made
in-house yeah so we can have control
over the sugar no added sugars none of
that kind of stuff so it's perfect to
have to make that we know that we can
make it in-house perfect and on top of
that you can do bulk or you can do light
right so lean
we have the two sizes to choose from so
good such a great service and now let's
talk about you know what you guys are
doing for our kids in title 1 elementary
school is jacob why don't you introduce
us to prep for school yeah so we've been
doing this foundation for about five
years now and we started off with one
school which is robert e lake
and now we've got to grow it to three
schools
so which is a huge accomplishment and we
are overly thrilled that we can do that
and our biggest goal this year was to
get 1700 backpacks into kids hands wow
so we're able to take that and
distribute out to the three schools matt
kelly and robert priest and uh with that
we are just just to see the kids
excitements and to see how when they get
the best video of it now exactly when
they get the bags on the first day of
school it's it's there's nothing like it
in the world yes it's so special it's
awesome well you know how can we help
you guys
are you asking for supplies
the best way to do it honestly is to
follow us on instagram okay and when you
do follow us on instagram you can see
there's a little link tree uh url there
up at the top you just click it and on
that little tab you'll see that the
donations page okay click that and
that thing is too small and too big
right
you guys make everything easy for us
food feeding the family keeping kids
good in school so thank you so much for
all you do what's the what's the
information for people to get in touch
with you guys website instagram all of
it all of the above okay what what's the
what's the foodiefitmeals.com
our instagrams will be at foodie fit
meal prep there you go you guys check
them out kendall sent it to you